Larry karaszewski along with this
writing producing partner Scott
Alexander is best known for making films
based on unusual true stories ed wood
man on the moon and big eyes over the
years they've won two Golden Globes two
Writers Guild Awards and last and last
season The Producers Guild Award and the
Emmy for creating the hit television
series the People vs OJ Simpson
presenting the award to max Lance and
Jen Bailey is Larry karaszewski
I've been in the Academy for close to 20
years and until this season I've never
been a part of the Nicholls Committee
but becoming a governor in the Writers
branch finally shamed me into doing my
fair share so the Academy sent me a big
stack of screenplays and I randomly
picked one from the pile I knew nothing
about the writers and nothing about the
plot I just started reading my first
script and about 10 pages in like
Twilight Zone music started playing
something weird was occurring I began to
come across some familiar characters
some very familiar characters names like
Robert Shapiro I started looking around
my house for hidden cameras like was I
being Punk'd
was I really reading another script
about the OJ Simpson case was i holding
season 2 but I kept reading and here's
the thing it was another good script
about OJ Simpson the writers had found
another interesting angle other
fascinating characters and other
pertinent topics to discuss the queen of
sleeves by max Lance and Jen Bailey
tells a sword tale of Judith Regan the
Fox media empire and the fiasco of OJ's
notorious if I did a book deal it's a
smart funny and complex look at the
grotesque 24 hours a day in news
infotainment industrial complex our show
was clearly an influence but it also
reminded me of a different film paddy
Chayefsky 's network Judith Regan is
Faye Dunaway's character made flesh
what was once satire is now reality and
the queen of sleaze does something
amazing it takes this complicated woman
and through masterful prose and dialogue
gives her humanity all while not denying
her flaws and mistakes the aspect that
impressed me the most about the writing
was it's tricky tone most writers
declare a major this is a serious drama
this is an absurd comedy but max Lance
and Gen Bailey know that real life is a
mixture of both and I'm proud to present
them with the Nichols fellowship
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone all right
well we'd like to thank the Academy for
this incredible fellowship and
opportunity Greg and Joan for putting
together such a wonderful wonderful week
thank my parents and my friends for
their love and support and all of their
babysitting a visa Brophy Scott Myles
next gown Matt Murphy this is for the
best writers group in Los Angeles my
parents tell me that it is wrong to get
a full time accounting job and then I
should pursue my dreams so thank you for
them in the same week two of my biggest
dreams came true I had a baby and I
started a career so well both are huge
accomplishments it's really dawning on
me that everything and it really feels
this way everything is just beginning
and this was my tenth submission to the
nickel with eight different scripts the
smartest thing I ever did was ask my
creative smart talented girlfriend at
the time if she wanted to write with me
two years ago the first script we
co-wrote reached the finals of the
nickel and then we got married that year
and then Wednesday she had our first kid
Monday we won the nickel so like you
know I owe this all to Jen and marriage
is not the scam I thought it was so like
she's a super woman this is amazing
Larry
[Applause]